Cacti are perpetual victims and kitten heart.
It's episode 34 of IMG!
When these guys get busy,
you get this.
And when Adobe adds the force to
Photoshop, you get Adobe WanKenobi.
If other brands did the same we'd have Jedi -
Do or do not; Sith puma; Hunt it your way
or Jabba the Hutt.
There's a smiley face on the surface of Mars
and starburst region NGC 3603 is the same.
Wedding photography can be mopey.
Uhmmm...
Packing enough heat to warm the bun in the oven.
A chair within a chair within a chair
within a chair chair-ception.
A tree chair
and an ergonomic... really? Let's move on to
a kitten with a permanent top hat
and some lesser-known last suppers.
Popeye,
cartoons, Team Fortress 2, other
video game characters and zombies.
If you're not hungry, skip the supper and just grab
a drink from Fremont coffee with
foam shaped into Batman, Darth Vader,
Frank from Donnie Darko or Pikachu.
Though, of course, I prefer Cthulhu-achu.
They also have Boba Fett, but I prefer
girls dressed
as Boba Fett. Enjoy.
For more action, check out Josh MC's
Disney Princess fighters -
Ariel, Belle, Jasmine, Snow White
and more.
Thanks to MoIllusions.com here
is some neon vomit. Stare at the black
dot in the middle and no matter what
don't move your eyes.
Slowly, but surely, the surrounding
collars will disappear into the grey.
Garret Steider designs alphabetical food posters.
If you look closely, you'll get it all over your face.
These pictures come from Mitsuko Nagone and finding them this week
made my week. On Facebook.com/vsaucegaming, Frederick showed us an
example of bad CD-rom design.
And Caleb's image of perfectly round circles hurt
my brain to try to understand.
Finally,
'Fouad' gave us these important acronyms.
And I'm not done there.
Click this to watch
Vsauce2's episode of LÜT, which is
just like this show but you can buy
everything on it. Be sure to subscribe to
Vsauce to keep the party going
and like us on Facebook to show your
friends that you have good taste.
Most importantly, no matter who you are
or what you do,
remember:
And as always,
thanks for watching.